I don't think that a lot of men
realize how scary just they.
Oh,
hi.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm from New Jersey originally and
I'm a publicist here in way. Hi Guys.
I'm Brett and I work in film.
I'm Gabby and I work in film
as well. I act. Hi everyone.
I'm Cory Aa. I'm from Los Angeles and
I'm in advertising and recruiting.
My name is far Huda. I'm born and raised
in La and I'm a writer and a director.
My name is Joe 25 years old and a
marketing coordinator here in La.
Yeah.
Not to say that this is a sound factor
that you know, there aren't exceptions,
but I think, you know, men are
there, they're built differently,
there's those stronger. Um,
usually I can say, yeah,
physically is a one inherent difference.
Obviously it changes based on like their
race and gender or like the like where
they're from and stuff like that.
But I think that women tend to sometimes
be a lot more over emotional and where
men tend to kind of respond a little
bit more stoically and that might not be
the most perfect way to say it,
but I think of it.
Do you think that's
unnatural way that we are,
we're born to be or do you think
that's how we're brought up?
I think it's a mixture of both.
Lexis oil might just be how
society has ingrained in them.
They should react to certain things
to men are supposed to be this like
sometimes uncompromising,
not unemotional person,
whereas the women are supposed
to be bullshit. Is that,
I think that people sometimes like fall
into those categories and even when
they're not supposed to be.
I feel like even as a man,
like you know how I approach
a problem is like, oh,
how can I fix this thing?
Whereas like a lot of my
female friends are like, like,
I don't need to fix it. I just need
to listen to this person. And uh,
and like for me, like that's just
not my natural impulse. Yeah.
There's so many men who people will say,
Oh yeah,
men are always stronger. Always this,
always that. Well tell that to a female,
UFC fighters will kick their ass.
You know what I'm saying?
And there are also a lot of options,
but there are a lot of people who will
say, oh, women are always hyper emotional.
And then to lead to a bleeding heart
guy who is just like the biggest,
most passionate person.
I mean,
so I just think generalization is
always problematic. My husband is,
he's one of those guys that cries
in like every movie, you know,
and like I love that. And I'm like, okay,
very assertive fiery person,
which is like generally attributed
to masculine and quality,
which in itself is problematic that we
think like strength is mass scale and
problem solving is masculine.
We're all capable and we're
all also have our weaknesses.
Ooh,
we gotta leave.
Definitely. I've experienced
a lot of disadvantages. Um,
it's been particularly in the workforce,
in my position, I'm pretty high up.
I kind of sit on the rights, you
know, right hand of the president.
But it's just kind of interesting how
I'm always left with all these like
administrative task, you know
what I mean? And I'm like,
well what about him and him and
him and him and him. But it's just,
I think it's natural for people to
associate administrative work with a,
you know, it's a feminine role. Same. Uh,
I work at a hardware store and which is,
I get looked over all the time cause
I'm like, hi, how can I help you?
And there go, I'm going to ask
this guy like literally just,
or not even talk to me.
They'll just walk right past me and
go ask a man to touch on more like
disadvantages,
like just having to think,
I think to be more conscious of a lot of
things like people say like walking to
your car at night or going for a jog
or just any, anything at night really.
In thinking about it, I was like, well
what is the disadvantage of being a man?
And I thought back to when
I was six, seven, eight,
and I was in the school yard and in
the classroom and my friends started to
police me because the girls
weren't getting policed.
From what I understand the way that the
boys, because the boys were being told,
don't be like a girl, don't
cry, don't share your emotions,
don't show your feelings.
Because I wanted to fit in.
I embodied those ideas
when I was considering this question,
you know,
do I have disadvantages based on
my gender? Impulsive and just, no.
Like as, as a white man
who raised in, you know,
middle class America, like right
off the bat, you have so many, um,
like lack of barriers I should say.
You have,
you have a lack of
barriers for opportunity.
Well, I just would like to let everyone
know that I do not open my own doors.
Don't miss seriously though. So if I'm
walking too, if I'm with a male, yeah,
if I'm walking to the door, I
won't touch the door. Um, however,
if I do open a door, if I'm by
myself, there's people behind me,
I'm keeping it open. And whole family,
females, males, no problem at all.
But if I'm with a male I will not open
the door. You just stand there. Yeah.
Look real stupid too. Cause they usually
stand there like as a joke and I'm like
where does that expectation come from?
Yeah.
I'm sure it was just the way I was raised
for me as a guy.
Like my instinct is like,
you know how my dad taught me and
my brother is just like, you know,
treat women with the
utmost respect and honor.
I feel like chivalry is just something
that I'm like this is absolutely
something I want to step into
and to continue and uphold. Yeah.
I think that's like a really beautiful
way to put it. I also think it's not true.
Like that's not born out of like
serve because she's up here.
It's because we don't, it's,
it's the opposite of empowerment.
The same reason why a guy
doesn't think that you can,
you know what?
Screw that is is the same reason why
they think they have to open the door or
why it hurts. Why chivalry
can hurt. Cause the,
the idea that like we have to protect
and we have to like do things for them,
it translates I,
it's equal to the idea that
because they are unable to,
generally speaking,
I always feel pretty comfortable
when I'm with the opposite gender.
I am the youngest and I have
three brothers and I have
a lot of male figures in
my life. So I think that that may
influence my feelings on that.
I grew up in a family full of women.
Literally mom had like three sisters,
like all of them have pretty much girls
until I was about 13 so 100% feel like
I'm comfortable with women being
around me. I'm a gay black man.
So literally the community just for gay
black people or just with gay people in
general,
you always have like your best girlfriend
that's going to be there on your side
regardless of whether you just met them
or whether you've known them for 25
years.
I don't think that a lot of men
realize how scary just they are.
And how many men just hanging
out, like feel like, oh,
that girl could literally kill me.
Like that's a true thing.
Come from a family that's like has
really strong female personalities.
You don't doubt that anything that they
can do because they went to dependence
on the family.
They were the ones that raise everybody.
They were the strongest people in
the family. So I don't, I don't know.
I understand you're, yeah,
I mean I, I in high school,
like I was on the wrestling team,
I was one of three girls on the all boy
wrestling team and I was like, yeah,
this is awesome. Like I'm one of the
guys, this is cool. And you know,
one of the guys like held
a knife to my throat,
like behind the bleachers at
a game. And you know, you,
you want to be able to trust and be like,
okay, I don't know you, so I'm going to,
you know, give me, give you
my trust for a little bit.
And then all of a sudden
you're on top of me. When,
when do I choose? And you're
like, who do I choose?
And so it's like I've never
had that with a woman. So,
ah,
I don't think I've always been comfortable
and I am a very private person. Um,
and so I'm very intentional about the
relationships that I build and about the
people who I am vulnerable.
I wasn't always comfortable sharing my
emotions in check from childhood to,
you know, my mid twenties or so. I
think it was more of just like dislike.
I mean bottle it up,
I'll share with a few people,
but it wasn't something
I would share freely.
And I think now where I'm at is I see
true power and vulnerability absolutely
share and not fear. Um, you
know, judgment or shame.
I am strong and the way that
I talk and just being strong,
people are like, oh, you're angry.
You're, you know, you're don't make sense.
I'm like, no, I make a
lot of sense right now.
You know,
you're awesome.
Just the fact that I have an emotion
makes me unreliable in some way.
And people's eyes. Like, we can't
have a woman running the country.
What if she's on her period? We'll go
to war. Well, I haven't seen it yet.
I am only uncomfortable in
how I am perceived because
I do want to be perceived
as a competent person and
somebody who can be trusted.
I have taught myself to become emotional,
but from my family and from
being a black person in America,
I don't think that I am
comfortable being emotional.
I feel like it's like me losing control.
It's me being vulnerable and I don't
like being vulnerable to anybody unless I
choose to.
And I think that bats,
it's a sad thing because like I should
be able to cry whenever I feel like it,
but I don't.
Or if I do cry,
like I lost a family member last
year and broke into tears and work.
As soon as I realized that I was crying,
I stopped and I said, I have to go home.
I apologize. I'm leaving
right now. And that's,
that's just how I had the respond to it.
And I don't think that's healthy,
but it's something that I that with,
that's just my personal experience
when it comes to being a male,
a black male in a marriage.
Yeah. I'm thinking it kind of goes back
to just women being the most approachable
people that I can come to and talk about
anything when it comes to me or just my
experience is a little,
like the things I've had to go through.
There are a lot more understanding
and I don't know, I just feel safe.
My experience again with
the opposite sex is it's
been pleasant. You know, my entire
life I've always felt comfortable.
I've always felt understood.
I've always felt like I had,
uh, uh, a voice, you know,
even if it's not again, the
voice in the conference room. Um,
I always felt like I've
always been respected.
I think like as a general role,
suave,
like take looking at it that way.
No men don't understand women and it's
because we're looking at it as two
different things.
Like even the idea of being
assertive comes off as being a bitch.
Are you speaking from a personal
place or societal place?
Cause I feel like you're,
you speak from a very
like big place instead of,
so it's all the same because
the question was like,
I not like society.
Yeah.
Do I feel understood by Matt? Yeah. No,
because they don't view me as an equal
in this space. Do you feel understood? Um,
I feel understood equally by all parties,
not, but, but you know, like, I sure,
you know, I believe that we're
all, um, image bearers, you know,
image bearers of God
and like bet were equal.
Then we're given these different roles
to fulfill. And then when you see, uh,
two people dancing and it's
a beautiful Cory graft,
equal dance, no one's out
showing the other person. Um,
but when it comes to like,
relationships with men and women,
like I feel like these
different roles can be such a,
a beautiful thing when done right,
but can also be a
disaster if one person is,
you know,
trying to outperform or other person
is taking advantage or overstepping.
Okay.
Like you said,
there's such a beauty in differences and
in masculinity and femininity and it's
important to have both in yourself
and you a picture.
You guys
okay?